the climb to the top of the tower is no
obstacle for this seven-year-old
please wait a minute her father Keisuke
kishimoto will be next up at the top is
the spot where border guards once
watched over the Berlin Wall
the Japanese family is visiting Berlin
for the first time and part of the trip
is a sobering lesson in recent German
history Keisuke kishimoto says he's
saddened by the symbolism of the tower
he knows that the soldiers who once
stood here prevented East Germans from
fleeing to the West and part of their
job was to shoot them if necessary by
chance some of the towers still exist
providing visitors with a bird's-eye
view of the past of the 155 kilometres
of wall that used to surround West
Berlin little remains today the tower is
located at potsdamer platz formerly a
barren no-man's land between the divided
sectors of Berlin our guide describes
how he and two others discovered the
tower after the fall of the Berlin Wall
he says it had been forgotten by the
city they knew this Tower built in 1969
was the oldest surviving remnant of the
division of Berlin it's the last Tower
of its kind so they fought to preserve
it they used to be 200 of them along the
border mister kishimoto does not
understand why the Germans have tried to
erase many traces of the former divide
we have to
remembered history here so that kind of
tower is very important I think
from the old and the new towers on
potsdamer platz we make our way through
the once divided city where socialism
and capitalism confronted each other
where the Cold War has left its mark on
different neighborhoods twenty-five
years after the fall of the wall as the
border really disappeared
there must be something left aside from
the familiar tourist magnets of
checkpoint charlie and the eastside
gallery
on the outskirts of Berlin there's a
freshly painted section of the wall and
behind it a curious story local
historian yo Arkham Kuhlman tells us
about one of the walls weak spots almost
a hundred people were shot trying to
scale the wall but none of them died
here a dead end residential street that
protruded into West Berlin surrounded on
three sides by the wall
Berliners called it the Ducks beak in
cool man says there was several escape
attempts here and all succeeded luckily
not a single shot was fired here because
none of the escapes were detected by the
border guards when they put itself on
England's understand take for me back
then the Schultz family lived on the
Walden Street and 25 years later there's
still a piece at the end of their garden
a machete Te'o shoot says he isn't
bothered by it actually it has its
advantages because the wall absorbs heat
and he can put plants there that
otherwise don't grow so well and he says
when the Berlin Wall was standing it
also had its good points too because
they never had to worry about break-ins
they didn't need to lock their doors
today he says it's different but he
doesn't wish to return to the Past Te'o
shows his fruit and vegetable garden
once marked the beginning of West Berlin
although the couple couldn't cross to
the other side they learned to live with
the reality of the war I asked Elizabeth
Schultz if they wave to their neighbors
in the house over in the West but she
says they weren't allowed she says a
family with three children lived next
door and on the other side of the wall
an old couple lived in a wooden house
the old couple sometimes threw over
chocolate for the children and the
family was forced to move out an old
photo shows Elizabeth Schultz in front
of the wall in her garden today it's
just part of the garden furniture
Elizabeth says that there used to be an
electric fence at the end of what is now
the vegetable patch the spot where she's
now standing was no-man's land with
Border Patrol's and to ensure that
nobody tried to escape
in the middle of Berlin less than three
kilometers from Alexanderplatz we find
another remnant of the border along the
river spray on a section of the former
death strip which hasn't been built on
there's a semi legal settlement known as
TP land about 30 people live here
constantly threatened by eviction they
come from Europe Asia and the Americas
Augustin is from Argentina and he built
his home himself along with all his
furniture for the past year he's been
living in tepee land and he says the
experience has taught him a lot about
creating something new out of waste he
builds with wooden shipping pallets
recycling them to fit his needs it's not
a community of anarchists they hold
meetings and Democratic votes and some
of the gardens almost appear bourgeois
another resident is Oliver Gore a former
banker from London
freedom is based in building really is
the place if you want to be a free
person you should live I mean they say
all the crazy people go to Berlin but
Berlin really for me is that and I mean
there's the gentrification coming and
all this kind of crazy capitalist
extremism but Berlin still hasn't gone
that far yet
an old bunker used by East German border
guards serves as the community center
Fernan Smits from Luxembourg looks after
the building the former restaurant
manager shows us around he says three
boats were moored here setting off to
patrol the river spring this old
telephone also dates back to that era
now they hold concerts and theater
performances in the space they also show
visitors around like some Chinese
tourists who have just turned up if you
want I can give you a to of the remains
of the wall here if you're interested
yeah of course I'll show you the wall so
that might be a bit more interesting for
you as well to film this small over here
used to be the wall from the restricted
zone the restricted zone is where you
need special passes to come and if you
pass the restricted zone they start
shooting at you
the Chinese students want to know why
the remains of the wall should be saved
to be preserved for future generations
that people not only just read about it
but actually can come and see those
things are they we're in the time when
the Berlin Wall was up you know
the dark side of the wall is the theme
of a nature walk for these school
children they're retracing the route of
the former death strip and they
discovered that the name should be taken
literally from their teacher Maryanne
chabela explains that this wooden board
is a memorial to mark the spot where you
are he Mir was shot dead as he tried to
escape across the border it shows that
he was born on April the 3rd 1945 and
shot on December the 3rd 1964 he was
just 19 years old when he died the
teacher tells his students that you re
mayor had his whole life in front of him
but he was killed because he wanted a
different life these students were born
after the wall came down
but yakit mayor's story makes it easier
for them to grasp the past as they dig
in the ground for a nature project they
stumble upon another piece of history
the students decide to unearth it it
appears to be a fence post from the old
border the 15 year-olds dig up the relic
25 years after the fall of the wall one
of the students points out a hole in the
post where an electric cable used to
pass through the cable registered every
movement information that was sent to
the watchtower that's still standing a
few meters away as well as teaching
Miriam Sybilla looks after the tower
found objects from the surrounding
forest are on display bits of the border
fence and spiked metz known as Stalin
grass which are today a rarity
Marianne says the German Historical
Museum in Bonn wanted the Stalin grass
as an exhibit but they refused to give
it away 25 years after the wall crumbled
in a political sense its physical
presence can still be found
you